[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of it
chapter 2 now understand I was a huge
huge fan of the first movie here and I
was so excited about this movie coming
out that I've actually read the whole
book of it this summer and if you don't
know it's chapter 2 and in chapter 1 are
all from this one book and there was a
miniseries in the 90s based off of the
book as well which had everything from
the book and what you have to understand
here is clearly that there wasn't any
adult parts in the it that we saw
recently in the first movie and that
came into play here whereas in the book
and the original miniseries they went
back and forth between adults and kid
like it's written so I what I've noticed
is that I think strategically by the
studio the first it they kept in all the
good stuff from the book which is mostly
with the kids and once I read the book
after seeing the first movie I realized
that the kid parts are the best parts by
far and that the adult parts were all
pretty boring and disappointing and I
was actually disappointed you know a lot
by the book it it is not a page-turner
it has great parts in it but those parts
that are memorable and that you love and
fall in with are all in the first movie
so it felt like this studio was like hey
you know what let's in this first movie
make sure this is a hit let's get this
to work it is a remake and Warner
Brothers need to hit bad and it worked
it made a great movie it was like The
Goonies version of it and now you're
kind of eating your cake here because
this movie felt a trap of dealing now
with all the boring parts of the book
and not having a balance and that is the
adult parts
and man were they bad and I didn't have
high expectations for this movie I loved
the first movie but I knew this would be
kind of an issue but I thought it would
still be pretty good but it was pretty
boring I'm gonna jump first actually
into the casting of this movie I think
that the casting was perfect except two
people and that would be the big stars
and James McAvoy and Jessica Chastain my
problem with James McAvoy is he did not
translate well to me if the original
bill the kid and I didn't feel that sync
up like this was the same person growing
up I think that was just a miscast
I don't blame James McAvoy for this I
think it was forced having him play bill
and I do blame him though for I think he
did the stuttering really well his
acting is always good but why did he
decide to have slip in there his voice
if you've seen the movie split that he
stars it when he does the does the same
voices in it it sneaks in here and there
and it just feels really weird and out
of place that is not bill now Jessica
Chastain I thought she played Jessica
Chastain she was not Beverly to me I
know she has red hair but that is not
enough Beverly is charming and there was
none of that charm translated from the
brilliant portrayal that Sophia listed
of Beverly as a kid that there was no
Tron and Jessica Chastain also dropped
the ball here to me she wasn't good at
screaming and that's actually underrated
technique and acting and a lot of
actresses are amazing at it and some you
know there is something to being a
scream queen and and Jessica just wasn't
great at it I didn't buy it every time
it felt half-hearted there and yeah
disappointing cuz I do like her other
stuff but I feel like she dropped the
ball here and again was just a miscast
everyone else I thought was perfectly
cast chillingly cast especially Stan
Lee's adult counterpart look just like
him and that includes Eddie here as well
and I got a dress obviously Bill Hader
he nailed it but he was also getting a
little too much praise I thought I mean
people were tweeting that this was an
oscar-worthy performance no it was
really good
he did solid but come on that that role
doesn't even have that opportunity there
and yeah I'm fine with who they cast it
has been as well and I really actually
thought the best one was the actor who
played Mike Hanlon grown up he's exactly
what I imagined in the book and I
thought he translated the best from his
child counterpart and I would say next
up after that obviously it's Bill Hader
the actor who played Eddie's adult
counterpart T turn on overacting a
little bit but he was still very good
so I actually disagree with the choice
here of really not making a bigger deal
about Bill's current wife Audra who's
supposed to represent someone who looks
just like Beverley I think that's a
strong actual part of the adult
storyline and the heart and soul of
Bill's choices here with Beverley and I
don't think it was smart to cut that out
I know they're trying to save time but
the things decided to keep in I think
they might have messed up there I also
think that they also should have kept in
more with Beverly's abusive husband
because it's in the book it really does
work well in retrospect or having an
abusive father and they did not play
that home at all so I thought those are
bad choices because what made the first
movie so great was the heart they're the
soul and the connection to the
characters which here felt soulless and
I didn't feel any weight to these adult
counterparts at all like I did with the
kids so as much as this book material
they were working with wasn't strong
they weren't helping themselves either
by picking by actually ignoring some of
the better stuff and that includes just
the simplicity of the main story here
which is Georgie the heart and soul of
this story of it is Bill's loss of his
brother they tickled that story here in
this movie but they kind of forgot about
it and that was a big misfire I mean
that's the base of the first movie and
to just let that go and not make a
bigger deal that especially at the end I
did not like that and I think that also
should have been brought up more even in
the last closing scenes and it wasn't
now I was a huge fan of Bill skarsgård
as penny wise in the first movie he's
still always great he's great here but
he does seem a little off and not as in
his zone
I feel like inconsistency is penny wise
in this one as he wasn't the first there
was moments it didn't feel like the
same clown that I remember and that
might just be his voice at times but
he's a shape-shifter so you can let that
pass a bit but I thought there was some
really weird scenes especially the one
with him and the little girl in the
bleachers one because there was so much
dialogue with Penny and wise there that
it made it feel odd and that we're
actually getting to know him and it
didn't feel like what Pennywise was
presenting himself as it was just like
this guy that's a clown and there was no
point of that scene that was just one of
the callous scenes there's no point to
it like why did we see this girl she
killed him his bleachers what did that
lead to it led to literally nothing in
the plot and you can even say that it
was a stretch just a story of Pennywise
killing the kid in the funhouse that
bill was after that that was just there
to be there and it wasn't a strong plot
link here and they were trying to make
it and give bill or lead something to do
it just felt very weird I think that
Pennywise his appearances were all
disappointing they weren't creative like
in the first one they were just you knew
the jump was coming you knew the scare
was coming and it would just turn into
something cgi based and way too heavy on
it and not believing enough in bill
skarsgård to let him do that just clown
side of penny wise always CGI and the
CGI seem dated that was hugely
disappointing because come on you can't
be cheap with this as a studio Warner
Brothers like this is your baby now it
was a hit why in the second one wouldn't
you put all the money into that and they
didn't they focused more on putting
money in de-aging these kids which was
very weird looking if you seen the
flashbacks obviously the actors of
Ritchie Eddie and Ben were de-aged in
different ways whether it was Ben's face
was altered a bit and they actually
shrunk Finn Woolf are two plays Ritchie
here because he got so tall and if
you've seen the actor of Eddie in Shazam
he's gotten much older looking as well
so they mess with him a bit and it just
felt weird watching that I didn't think
it was the best the aging effects
especially with Ritchie I felt like I
was just watching a weird like video
game happened here and that took me out
of it that he wasn't really there and a
lot of the
humor here didn't land that that was and
I expected it to land more and it really
didn't I mean it was some pretty lame
joke right anything the best humor
obviously which would be expected was
any improvising but Bill Hader here but
other than that I mean there was some
tonal issues here they didn't know
exactly what they wanted to be this
movie and I think that screamed
completely when Eddie as an adult gets
all that sludge shot on his face and
they play that music to make it like a
comedy and it was like what what is this
like I don't understand is this now
trying to also mess with Marvel humor
and that's frustrating cuz that doesn't
fit it to me and they tried doing that a
lot in this especially like when Richie
Neddy see the cat through the doors and
it just is like a dire situation but
they have to stop it to have this humor
and that's totally the Marvel thing they
do in their movies and it just it just
took me out of it there too I was like
come on what what are you trying to be
here don't be so business based in these
decisions and what works for audiences
it the first it worked just stick to
what work did that's all he was just so
frustrating bout this movie and that's
also with like sequels having that trap
of wanting to be bigger and that makes
it better and it usually doesn't and
that comes just with the grand finale
hero it was like this giant spider based
off the book idea but it was just
becoming a CGI fest and I always hate
that you've seen that my reviews I just
hate when they fight a big monster and
it's just too long they just dragged
that scene out and you just don't feel
the same weight as you did when in the
first movie when they're fighting penny
at the end he's changing and all things
that are afraid of and you're connected
to so this was the problem this just
became your classic typical blockbuster
monster movie and honestly I felt zero
tension in this movie and suspense and
that's a huge problem too and that has
to go on the director it has to go on
the editors and has to go on the writer
here and you got to understand you see
that it's the same writer and director
from the first movie gives you hope but
there's always a little reason behind
writing and why it could downgrade and
of course to the writers from the first
movie aren't on it you can already see a
difference here you got a notice those
little details and casting and crew
because it makes a whole lot of
difference and it always comes back to
the writing here
and it was weak but giving writer a
little credit Stephen King who I love
but also is not perfect and it is over
long the book as was this movie and
unfortunately this movies really tough
to get there because it's just the
really boring parts of the book and that
also goes through Stephen King's writing
as well I did like the Stephen King
cameo again though felt like a Stan Lee
cameo is a Marvel but I still think that
kind of work you can get away with that
but again stop trying to be all the
other big blockbusters you already were
in your own way so that's a lot of
criticism I've thrown at it but the
positives for me were again I think
besides those two in James McAvoy and
Jessica Chastain and casting I thought
was excellent you couldn't have done a
better job I think the kids are still
great actors here and their chemistry is
off the charts which I wish adults that
the adults could have emulated better I
think that man there's really not much I
liked about this movie
I think the editing was pretty good for
what it was given to edit with and I
think that they had really good
transitions from from one time to
another they did that really smoothly
and that felt like there was an effort
put there but the rest just felt like a
mishmash and a slog I'm gonna give this
one a harsh rating and it actually
doesn't even have to do with me being
super hyped about it or anything like
that it's just what I watched what I saw
happening as a movie it was not good so
I'm giving it a five point five I think
they should definitely just let this
rest now it's a disappointment it's a
disappointing sequel there's been a lot
of those in Hollywood lately and I think
obviously business ruins and money a lot
of these decisions but I was just upset
because I thought it would stay true to
good writing and focusing on what that
heart that the first one had and they
just didn't just became your
middle-of-the-road
monster movie that also again wasn't
scary and got cheesy at time so five
point five for me let me know you
thought oh this will be done below I'd
love to hear your thoughts and please
subscribe so I miss one of my reviews I
do a bunch of movies TV shows and I also
do
interviews as well so check those out
and please follow me at Steve are they
wanted on Twitter Instagram for more of
me and I'll see you next time